y a la vez intentar gestionar mi negocio real.
Incluso llegué a bromear con que lo había presentado a regañadientes
a todos mis familiares, amigos, colegas, padrinos inversores
e inversores de riesgo de esta orilla del Mississippi.
En el proceso de hablar con todos estos inversores,
noté que sucedía algo muy curioso.
Me planteaban preguntas muy distintas a las de mi cofundador masculino.
A mí me preguntaban sobre todo lo que podía salir mal con el proyecto
y provocar pérdidas al inversor,
mientras que a mi socio le preguntaban sobre el potencial de la empresa
de maximizar los beneficios del inversor,
básicamente, todo lo que podía salir bien con el proyecto.
A él le preguntaban cuántos nuevos clientes atraeríamos
mientras que a mí me preguntaban como mantendríamos a los actuales.
Como CEO de la compañía, esta situación me parecía extraña.
De hecho, me sentía como si estuviese paranoica.
Pero finalmente lo racionalicé pensando
que quizá tenía que ver con cómo me presentaba,
o que era algo simplemente único de mi empresa.
Años después tomé la dura decisión de dejar mi empresa
para poder cumplir mi sueño de conseguir mi doctorado.
Fue en Columbia donde aprendí sobre una teoría psicológica social
creada por el profesor Tory Higgins denominada "foco regulador",
que diferencia entre dos orientaciones motivacionales distintas
de promoción y prevención.
El foco en la promoción se preocupa por las ganancias
y enfatiza la esperanza, logros y necesidades de avance,
mientras que el foco de prevención se preocupa por pérdidas
y enfatiza la prudencia, responsabilidad y necesidades de seguridad.
Dado que el mejor escenario para un foco de prevención
es simplemente mantener el status quo,
esto supone dedicar esfuerzos para solo seguir a flote,
mientras que un foco de promoción nos hace nadar en la dirección correcta.
Es cuestión de hasta dónde podemos avanzar.
Tuve mi propio momento "eureka" cuando me di cuenta
de que el concepto de promoción
sonaba mucho como las preguntas planteadas a mi socio,
mientras que la prevención me recordaba a las que me hacían a mí.
Como estudiante de emprendimiento,
empecé a indagar en los estudios sobre financiación de proyectos
y descubrí que hay una diferencia abismal
entre los fondos que consiguen empresarios femeninos y masculinos.
Aunque las mujeres crean el 38 % de las empresas estadounidenses
solo consiguen el 2 % de la financiación de riesgo.
Me puse a pensar:
¿y si esta diferencia de fondos no se debe a ninguna diferencia fundamental
en los negocios emprendidos por hombres y mujeres?
¿Y si las mujeres consiguen menos fondos
a causa de la simple diferencia en las preguntas que les plantean?
En definitiva, cuando se trata de financiar proyectos,
los emprendedores deben convencer a los inversores del potencial del proyecto.
No basta con demostrar
que no van a perder el dinero de sus inversores.
Tiene lógica que las mujeres consigan menos fondos que los hombres
si están vinculadas
a la prevención en vez de a diálogos orientados a la promoción.
Pude poner a prueba esta hipótesis
en empresas de calidad y necesidad de fondos similar a lo largo de años
en el concurso de financiación llamado TechCrunch Disrupt
que Startup Battlefield ha celebrado en Nueva York
desde su creación en 2010.
TechCrunch es considerada la plataforma ideal para el lanzamiento de empresas,
con empresas participantes que se han convertido en grandes marcas
como Dropbox, Fitbit y Mint
presentándose ante los inversores de riego más importantes.
A pesar de la similitud de las empresas de mi muestreo,
las dirigidas por hombres conseguían cinco veces más fondos
que las dirigidas por mujeres.
Esto hizo que sintiese curiosidad por ver qué causaba esta disparidad de género.
Me llevó un tiempo,
pero conseguí todos los vídeos de las presentaciones y sesiones de preguntas
de TechCrunch e hice que las transcribiesen.
Primero analicé las transcripciones
descargando un diccionario de términos centrados en regulación
en el programa de consulta lingüística y contador de palabras llamado LIWC.
El LIWC indicó la frecuencia
de palabras promoción y prevención en la transcripción.
Como segundo método,
mandé codificar manualmente todas las preguntas y respuestas
por el Tory Higgins Research Lab de Columbia.
Independientemente del tema,
puede encuadrarse una intención en la promoción o en la prevención.
Volvamos al tema de los clientes que he mencionado antes.
Una pregunta de promoción suena como:
"¿Cuántos clientes planea conseguir este año?"
mientras que una de prevención suena como:
"¿Cómo planea mantener a sus clientes actuales?"
Durante el mismo tiempo
recopilé información previa
sobre proyectos y emprendedores que puede afectar a su financiación,
como la antigüedad de la empresa, calidad y cantidad de fondos necesarios
y la experiencia previa del emprendedor
para poder usar estos datos como controles en mi análisis.
Lo primero que descubrí fue
que no existen diferencias en cómo los emprendedores presentan sus empresas.
Es decir, tanto los emprendedores como las emprendedoras
usan niveles similares de lenguaje de promoción y de prevención
en sus mensajes.
Habiendo descartado esta diferencia por parte de los emprendedores,
me fijé en los inversores
analizando los seis minutos de las sesiones de preguntas
entre emprendedores y capitalistas de riesgo tras la presentación.
Al examinar las cerca de 2.000 preguntas
y sus respuestas en estas conversaciones,
ambos métodos mostraron pruebas significativas
de que a los emprendedores se les hacen preguntas de promoción
y a las emprendedoras, preguntas de prevención.
De hecho, un enorme 67 % de las preguntas planteadas
a los emprendedores se centraban en la promoción,
mientras que el 66 % de las planteadas a las emprendedoras eran de prevención.
Lo especialmente interesante
es que esperaba que las inversoras
se comportasen de manera similar a los inversores hombres
Dada su prevalencia en los medios y en la literatura de financiación empresarial,
esperaba que la teoría homofílica del apoyo entre iguales estaría presente,
de manera que los inversores favorecerían a los emprendedores
con preguntas de promoción
y que has inversoras harían lo propio con las emprendedoras.
Pero todos los inversores demostraron el mismo sesgo de género implícito
manifestado en el foco regulador de las preguntas planteadas
a los candidatos frente a las candidatas.
Así, las mujeres inversoras preguntaban a los emprendedores preguntas de promoción
y a continuación formulaban a las emprendedoras preguntas de prevención,
al igual que hacían los inversores.
Teniendo en cuenta que tanto inversores como inversoras
muestran esta sesgo de género implícito,
¿qué efecto tiene, si lo hay, en la financiación de las empresas?
Mi estudio demuestra que tiene un efecto significativo.
El foco regulador de las preguntas del inversor
no solo predijeron qué tan bien funcionarían los proyectos
en las competencias de TechCrunch Disrupt
sino también cuántos fondos recaudarían los proyectos en el mercado abierto.
Los proyectos a los que se plantearon más preguntas de promoción
consiguieron siete veces más financiación
que aquellos con preguntas de prevención.
Pero no lo dejé aquí.
Seguí analizando las respuestas de los emprendedores a las preguntas
y descubrí que los emprendedores responden de acuerdo al tipo
de preguntas planteadas,
es decir, una pregunta de promoción genera una respuesta de promoción
y una pregunta de prevención genera una respuesta de prevención.
Esto nos puede parecer intuitivamente lógico,
pero conlleva consecuencias indeseables para la financiación de proyectos.
Lo que acaba ocurriendo
es que al emprendedor hombre se le plantean preguntas de promoción
brindándole el lujo de reforzar su vínculo
con el ámbito favorable de las ganancias y respondiendo en consecuencia,
mientras que a una emprendedora se le plantean preguntas de prevención
y de manera inadvertida agrava su asociación
con el ámbito desfavorable de las pérdidas.
Estas respuestas provocan a su vez preguntas parciales de los inversores
y las preguntas y respuestas alimentan un ciclo de prejuicios
que simplemente perpetúa la desigualdad de género.
Bastante deprimente, ¿verdad?
Por suerte hay un rayo de esperanza en mis descubrimientos.
Los valientes emprendedores que lograban cambiar el foco
respondiendo a preguntas de prevención con respuestas de promoción,
consiguieron 14 veces más financiación
que los que respondieron a preguntas de prevención
con respuestas de prevención.
Esto significa que si les preguntan
acerca de defender la cuota de mercado de su empresa,
lograrán mejor resultado si enmarcan su respuesta
en el tamaño y potencial de crecimiento de su parte del pastel
en vez de simplemente en cómo planean proteger su parte del pastel.
Así que si me preguntasen esto,
respondería:
"Jugamos en un mercado tan amplio y de crecimiento tan rápido
que atrae a nuevos participantes.
Planeamos ampliar nuestra presencia en este mercado
aprovechando los activos únicos de nuestro proyecto".
Así he redirigido el diálogo sutilmente hacia el área favorable de las ganancias.
Estos resultados son bastante convincentes en el ámbito de proyectos de TechCrunch
pero los datos de campo simplemente nos muestran la relación correlativa
entre el foco regulador y la financiación.
Así que intenté ver si esta diferencia en el foco regulador
podía realmente causar resultados en la financiación
haciendo un experimento controlado
en padrinos inversores y en gente común.
Recreé el entorno del TechCrunch Disrupt
con participantes que escucharon audios de cuatro a seis minutos
de diez intercambios de preguntas y respuestas
que se habían manipulado con lenguaje de promoción y prevención
y les pedimos que asignasen una cantidad de fondos
a cada proyecto según su criterio.
Los resultados de mi experimento reforzaron mis descubrimientos anteriores.
Cuando a los emprendedores se les hacían preguntas de promoción,
recibían el doble de asignación de fondos
que aquellos emprendedores con preguntas de prevención.
Lo que resulta esperanzador
es que en los casos en los que los emprendedores modificaban
en vez de mantener el enfoque asignado al plantearles preguntas de pervención,
recibían fondos notablemente mayores de ambos grupos de inversores.
Para todas las mujeres emprendedoras,
hay un par cosas simples que pueden hacer.
La primera es reconocer el tipo de pregunta que le plantean.
¿Es una pregunta de prevención?
Si es así, respondan siempre lo que se les pregunta,
pero enmarquen su respuesta en la promoción
en un esfuerzo por conseguir mayor financiación para su proyecto empresarial.
Sin embargo, la triste realidad
es que tanto hombres como mujeres que analizan proyectos
demuestran el mismo sesgo de género implícito en sus preguntas
favoreciendo inadvertidamente a los emprendedores sobre las emprendedoras.
A todos los inversores
les digo que tienen la oportiunidad
de plantear las entrevistas de manera más imparcial,
no solamente para hacer lo correcto,
sino para mejorar la calidad de su toma de decisiones.
Arrojando la misma luz en el potencial de todos los proyectos empresariales
de ganancias y pérdidas,
permiten que brillen todos los proyectos que lo merecen
y maximizan los resultados en el proceso.
Hoy soy yo esa joven
que pasea cerca de la piscina
y hace sonar la alarma
de que algo está mal bajo la superficie.
Juntos tenemos el poder de romper este círculo
de sesgo de género implícito en la financiación empresarial.
Ofrezcamos a los proyectos empresariales más prometedores
sin importar si son dirigidos por hombres o mujeres,
la oportunidad de luchar para crecer y prosperar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)